donc j'ai les couilles je sais que bah
là dès qu'il aime pas qu'on lui fasse
des vannes sur sur sa vie privée sur la
drogue ou sur Sarkozy malik Bentalha
bonsoir
et maintenant j'accueille mon stagiaire
comme villa
[Applaudissements]
bon c'est gentil c'est gentil ça me fait
plaisir enfin tu verras il vaut mieux un
bon CDD tu es un mauvais CD c'est vrai
mais comme j'ai pas de CDD non plus on
est dans la merde bravo Thierry très
très beau plateau très très éclectique
ce soir Liane Foly Liane Foly bonsoir
bonsoir alors votre prénom c'est Eliane
fayex
un nom de médicament un petit peu
vite j'ai pris deux paliers
vous avez choisi folie comme pseudo en
hommage à Salvador Dali je crois qu'il
la met dans une pub qu'il était fou de
chocolat heureusement que vous avez pas
choisi la pub au vomaltine maintenant
parce que sinon liane dynamite ça fait
plus drag queen que artiste quand même
alors vous sortez un disque de reprise
qui s'appelle kronneuse voilà d'ailleurs
mais je crois que vous aimez pas trop le
terme de reprise préférée relooking et
je suis entièrement d'accord avec ça
c'est vraiment on dit pas un ravalement
de façade mais un lifting et et on lit
pas une sodomie mais un itinéraire
bonsoir Éric de l'Académie française
s'il vous plaît ça peut s'applaudir très
très fort
ça sert à rien
à l'Académie française contrairement à
la voiture tous les fauteuils sont à la
place du mort
mais non mais c'est vrai vu la moyenne
d'âge de l'Académie française
Eric vous avez 69 ans mais c'est un peu
le Justin Bieber voilà c'est ça
quand il sort il va draguer des gamines
de 75 ans et non mais d'ailleurs en fait
pour entrer à l'Académie française c'est
un peu comme avec Nagui avec son jeu
tout le monde veut prendre sa place bon
sauf que là à l'Académie l'élimination
est beaucoup plus définitive
que Orsenna c'était pas votre vrai nom
non plus [ __ ] c'est la soirée des
pseudos ce soir c'est votre prénom c'est
Eric Arnoult et vous tenez le nom
d'Orsenna de la vieille ville du rivage
des cirtes dans le roman de Julien GRAC
voilà donc tu vois liane il s'est un peu
plus cassé le cul quand même mais
donc gynéco Doc Gynéco bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
je sais que il aime pas qu'on lui fasse
des vannes sur sur sa vie privée sur la
drogue ou sur Sarkozy malik Bentalha
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
alors malik Bentalha vous venez le voir
pour Pattaya Thierry juste une question
ce qui vient encore pour Pattaya vous
savez qu'on a reçu tous les comédiens de
bataille j'adore ce film non mais vous
avez des ronds dans le film ou quoi
la semaine prochaine c'est qui c'est le
mec du son c'est du samedi matin je me
suis tapé un ladyboy sans faire exprès
j'ai confondu les perches faut arrêter
de rire un peu quand même non mais Malik
je l'aime beaucoup parce qu'en plus on a
le même âge tu fais du stand-up je fais
du stand-up tu as bosse avec Morandini
je bosse avec Morandini tu fais du
cinéma je bosse avec morandini
[Rires]
on lui donne des vrais rôles de
composition genre Pattaya il joue une
caméra dans la vache il joue une caméra
dans New York il jouait une caméra qui
c'est qui ton agence et Rohff c'est
un film bonne nouvelle il va jouer un
épicier donc on évite les clichés ça
c'est la ça c'est très bien mesdames et
messieurs je suis ici pour vous poser
les questions trop con que Thierry
Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous poser
Eric Orsenna ola Eric vous avez été la
plume de de François Mitterrand vous
savez que si vous avez été la plume de
Frédéric Mitterrand vous auriez pas fini
au même endroit non
[Rires]
vous avez dit je suis une femme qui aime
le miracle de la vie c'est vous ou du
Roi Lion
c'est un peu moins de Disney
et pour terminer dog vous dites parfois
dans la rue une voiture s'arrête et les
gens m'insultent en même temps vous
savez que si vous traversez la même
vitesse que vous parlez c'est normal
merci voilà c'était top notre stagiaire
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu